Oh
[Music]
it's the first official Star Wars
spin-off movie well okay we've had a
couple before but the first one to be
shown on the big screen okay maybe this
isn't as big a deal as I thought buts
the first live-action one to be shown on
big screen Star Wars rogue one focuses
on the mission to get the secret plans
that blow up the Death Star oh thank god
I'm finally gonna see what a boffin
looks like what it's the first one no I
wouldn't see a button okay so the story
as best as I can tell because it is very
difficult to tell because it jumps
around a lot a young girl's family is
killed by the Empire years later she
grows up gets captured by the Empire but
then gets saved by the rebellion and
they offer her to join why because her
father it turns out is the one who's
designing the Death Star well her focus
is more to get him back alive the
rebellions focus is more to get the
plans that show how the Death Star is
made and how to destroy it being joined
by a colorful band of characters like
characters I mean one yeah okay one and
a half they set out to retrieve the plan
save her father and of course die
because you know exactly how this is
gonna turn out but that's okay if they
make the characters enjoyable and
likeable it'll be all the more tragic
and yeah not really
nope we put this way the characters
aren't unlikable in any way I mean
there's nobody that came on-screen and I
just said oh god not this person it's
just well they're all kind of boring or
even just weird the person who raised
our main character I think raised her
anyway again not all that clear not only
has a very strange voice but has a very
odd scene with this squid monster that
can read minds and it never seems to go
anywhere there's a last seems kinda like
that where people will kind of be flying
from planet to planet doing weird thing
after weird thing and it never seems to
amount to much
mostly because while the characters
motivations are clear there's not really
that much charm to them the only - like
I said before I actually do kind of
remember our robot who again is snarky
and comedic and kind of getting sick of
these robots how about a robot villain
didn't they do that one of the LucasArts
games anyway and the other is this blind
guy who puts all his faith in the force
literally all his faith he lets it guide
him he lets him know where Stormtroopers
are so he can whack him with a big stick
yes the Ewoks could do it why not him
big sticks
watch out Empire and I almost threw his
friend on there to who's always trying
to look after him but he really doesn't
have much of a character either his only
likable personality trait is that he
knows this guy and he's with him
I don't really know that much about him
outside of that to make things even
worse the villain is boring you really
feel like you could have given like this
really creepy disturbing kind of empire
villain but they just resurrect another
one to do that for some reason at the
time if you said the CG look awkward
everybody just thumped on you they
couldn't believe that you thought that
but guys really look at this it's
already starting to become dated don't
get me wrong it's good but there's still
that uncanny valley there particularly
around the lips like a lot of people I
would have liked it more if you just saw
his reflection in the glass but if they
want to do this all the way okay I guess
it's kind of cool to see van Helsing
back from the dead the more I think
about it but okay those are my problems
with the movies and granted they are big
problems but let's talk about the good
stuff this is the first Star Wars movie
where I really felt like I was there
something about the way they shoot it
something about the pacing something
about the way it really lets you kind of
sit in these environments it's not
always shot really showy it's shot kind
of matter of fact there's a really great
shot when they see a Star Destroyer in
the air and it kind of tilts up and you
just really feel like you're looking at
it from a great distance
the action sequences are also
legitimately good especially at the end
these may be some of the best base
battles that ever been in Star Wars
honestly I think a lot of people's
enjoyment of this movie is the final act
because the action is not only so good
but it's aggressive and it feels real it
feels like an actual war movie it is
called Star Wars it's nice that it
finally feels like an actual war also
I've gone on and on about how phenomenal
this last two minutes of Darth Vader is
if you haven't seen it I won't spoil a
thing just check it out it's really
awesome when this movie came out
audiences were kinda split though not
really die-hard the people who disliked
it didn't hate it they just thought it
was kind of generic the people who liked
it though loved the hell out of it I
sort of sat around wondering why that
could be and I think it finally hit me
because the characters are not on
likeable or annoying or a pain in the
ass like in some other Star Wars movies
and the fact that shot in such a
realistic warlike environment I think
people feel like they're putting
themselves in those roles they're left
just blank slate ish enough that they
can feel like they're really in the
action and the action is gritty and real
I think those Star Wars fans and action
movie fans want to feel like they're a
fly on the wall either listening to this
conversation by the Empire or feeling
like they're one that people running on
the beach getting an adrenalin rush as
things are firing at you I guess it's
kind of a Saving Private Ryan of Star
Wars films if you want to put it that
way
and honestly I'm totally down for that I
love those elements about this movie I
just wish that the characters were a lot
more interesting
I wanted to want what they want I wanted
to fear what they fear I wanted their
passion but it just doesn't look like
they had any passion either the acting
is always so stilted and dry and the
dialogue is always very straight forward
I can go on and on about the personality
of the original Star Wars characters but
these guys not so much still I am kind
of a sucker for really good environments
a nice action and yeah when the
characters from the Year Star Wars
movies do come in it is kind of cool it
feels like it captures their voice
pretty well I like the idea of a darker
harsher Star Wars story I just wanted
done more with people that you can
connect with and maybe that's why so
many changes were made to the movie as a
lot of articles say maybe the characters
were too likable maybe we did enjoy them
too much you know they're gonna die and
you want people to come back to this
movie so you shouldn't make them too
interesting just enough to feel sad but
satisfied enough to come back and see it
again but I don't know I have no idea
what went into making this movie all I
can comment on is the final product and
what we got is okay the cool scenes are
really friggin cool you just got way
through a lot of okay stuff to get to it
but I know a lot of people who love this
movie so maybe you'll be one of them
there's only one way to know for sure
fly on in and check it up